for my talk at the table we are
introducing you to Tony award-winning
actor Jane Krakowski who's bringing
Broadway's Razzle Dazzle to our screens
on Apple TV plus the hit series
schmigodoon is about a married couple
Josh and Melissa who found love in the
musical theater town of smigadoon in the
second season Krakowski plays the
high-flying Bobby Flanagan whose talents
including splits acrobatics and roller
skating folks while blindfolded okay uh
this new season is set in Chicago the
reimagined world of 60s and 70s musical
Josh played by Keegan Michael Key finds
himself framed for murder and in this
preview he is visited by his new lawyer
Bobby Flanagan take a look at this
Bobby
[Music]
Flanagan attorney at law your mistress
hired me tall Burnett kind of
complaining that's my wife
so do you think you can get me out of
here I don't know but I'm gonna get paid
trying first things first don't tell me
why you did it I don't need to know it I
didn't do it don't need to know that
either just do what I tell you winning a
case is all about Flim Flam flap doodle
and Pizzazz slap doodle the law is 10
precedent and 90 wow lucky for you I'm
very good at wow
joins us now good morning good morning I
am so happy to be here we're so glad to
have you you are so thank you and she
bought the Razzle Dazzle today thank you
thank you oh man we're so excited um
okay first let's talk Bobby Flanagan who
I mean uh she's the type of lawyer who
has and I'm quoting here has her garter
belt and stockings showing at all times
a little bit of inspiration from perhaps
Billy Flynn absolutely I play Bobby
Flanagan which I guess is a gender swap
of Billy Flynn she's a morally flexible
lawyer
who has a lot of Razzle Dazzle and will
ring every Bell and whistle to win the
case so what I love about this is um
you're thrilled to star in the second
season of schmooga Dune um which you
called your dream project I loved you in
the first season you played uh the
Countess yeah uh and I I there was a
vibe that made me think that you were
modeling that character a little bit off
the baroness in The Sound of Music who
like headline everybody liked fraudline
Maria or maybe Liesel I was a baroness
guy oh wow I was a bear in this guy and
you gave me shades of the baroness yes I
was absolutely
absolute season was based in the golden
Asian musicals it was called shmika Dune
and we were celebrating gingham and corn
puddin now we're in Chicago we're in a
whole we're not in smigadoon anymore
we're in Chicago it's the darker edgier
musicals of the 60s and 70s and we've
traded in the corn pudding for garter
belts murder absinthe you know a lot of
good stuff you know what I love Jane I
love the writing on this show it's so
clever I just have three great Bobby
lines she says there's very little I
can't do except boar look bad in any
kind of suit clothes are amazing to a
character who's getting very teary she
goes are you getting emotional or
contagious I prefer the latter and best
last I'm not the best at Consolation I
was born by Cold birthday check writers
I mean the dialogue in this is so good
you called this a dream project for you
how come well it's a dream project
because it combines my two favorite
loves that I do in this business my my
love of Broadway and musical theater and
then my love of Television comedy and it
puts it all together our writer single
Paul is so clever and so smart and I
think if you know musical theater you're
going to understand how intricate and
cleverly the show is written and if you
don't you're just going to love it
because it's an entertainment musical
the music is so great yeah if you love
musicals this is this is for you and
then at one point you do the splits
there's a thing bells and whistles
there's a very fast rattat-tat can you
do that or no
it's really it's a really complicated
vocal piece that has been inserted into
my big number which is from the musical
company we all sort of have amalgams of
different musicals and and
characterizations in our part
um I think it's thank you to the judge
and all the members of the jury I will
try to make this brief because I know
you're in a hurry see my client the
defended Dr Joshua diskin and he was
merely at the club to take his darling
Mike to dinner he stumbled on the body
of Miss Celsius and it goes on and on I
know that's amazing I know then it ends
in the splits and you do the splits when
you have to learn something that's that
complicated and fast I think it never
leaves you because I didn't practice
that before we came out I realized I'd
practice it so much before we filmed it
that it's still in there that's amazing
Bravo so from things you had to practice
things you had to learn there are
trapeze stunts in this show and you went
to Trapeze school after requesting even
more a trapeze not to be written into
the script so what was that experience
like well my number is called bells and
whistles so I literally had to exhaust
my special skills list on my resume
um I had to bring in any skill that I
could do into the number it was written
in that she enters on a trapeze and I
was like well could I try a few more
tricks just because that stuff's fun for
me I love it I made my Broadway debut on
roller skates which I think was a in a
show called Starlight Express I remember
Starlight Express yes
vacation yeah oh wow so I think because
I started with that sort of sporting
event kind of Broadway show I love to
add any physical element into the show
so they let me go and take a bunch of
trapeze lessons and we threw in as many
tricks as I could you were so fun so
gorgeous so smart and so good at what
you do and now there's a lot there's a
movement on foot online for White Lotus
season I know please hello Mike White
I'm absolutely thankful you would love
to do it right oh my God who wouldn't I
think oh I said it's burning up ready
everybody on the like theater Message
Board the Nerds were all yes
I'd love it that would be a dream come
true and how's your favorite son how old
now oh my favorite and only son
um is uh he's just turned 12. we had his
birthday this past weekend oh
congratulations
ice skating and do you does he
understand I remember when he was a
little boy does he understand what you
do
I think he does uh yeah you know when
when he first watched the number and he
saw that section that we just talked
about that fast talking about he goes my
favorite part was when you wrapped like
Eminem
it's on time but all right okay I'll
take it Sondheim was Eminem before
Eminem
so wonderful to meet you in person come
on White Lotus Jane Krakowski care for
it jacobski is available uh but
meanwhile new episodes of the second
season of smiggadoon are currently
streaming on Apple TV Plus